[Applaus]
[Musik]
die wissenschaft war schon oft in der
lage mit hilfe einer gewaltigen
kraftanstrengung schier unmöglich
scheinende dinge in unglaublich kurzer
zeit zu vollbringen wenn ihr nur die
entsprechenden ressourcen und jede menge
motivation zur verfügung standen
dazu zählen die entwicklung der ersten
atombombe im rahmen des manhattan
project der wettlauf um die landung des
ersten menschen auf dem mond und die
entschlüsselung des menschlichen genoms
tja und was würdet ihr dazu sagen wenn
ich jetzt einfach mal so behaupte dass
all diese megaprojekte wie ein
kinderspiel erscheinen angesichts des
vorhabens einen sicheren und effektiven
impfstoff gegen das corona wie just
cause 2 innerhalb eines jahres für
milliarden von menschen verfügbar zu
machen
[Musik]
denkt er jetzt kommt schon markt
übertreibst du nicht ein wenig impfungen
gegen andere krankheiten gibt es schon
lange der erste impfstoff der geschichte
wurde doch bereits im jahre 1798 also
vor über 200 jahren erfunden und ja wir
haben natürlich recht damit dass es ist
doch nichts neues sind vollkommen neu
ist jedoch der ambitionierte zeitrahmen
in denen die impfung gegen kuwait 19
entwickelt werden und massenhaft
ausgerollt werden soll ehrlich gesagt
ist dies nach dem heutigen stand der
wissenschaft einen geradezu verrückter
plan glaubt ihr nicht nur dann hört euch
mal folgendes an es dauerte 15 jahre um
den treibstoff gegen humane papillom zu
entwickeln einen geeigneten folie und
stoff der die kinderlähmung besiegte
fand man erst nach 20 jahren intensiver
forschung und bis heute gibt es noch
keinen impfstoff gegen stars oder aids
obwohl daran schon seit vielen
jahrzehnten mit hochdruck gearbeitet
aber womit es geht hier nicht nur um die
forschungsarbeit selbst wenn es gelänge
den perfekten impfstoffe coup mit 19 zu
entwickeln müsste danach noch die
gewaltigste impfkampagne aller zeiten
durchgeführt werden dabei ist von 7
milliarden impfdosen die rede
und wenn du jetzt glaubt dies alles wäre
nur eine frage des geldes großer irrtum
denn manche entwicklungen brauchen nun
mal unbedingt vor allem zeit und
sorgfalt sie lassen sich nicht dadurch
beschleunigen indem man viel geld drauf
wir sprechen hier sowohl von solider
wissenschafts arbeit als auch von der
entscheidenden macht des zufalls vom
aufbau logistischer strukturen als auch
von der schaffung einer komplexen
wertschöpfungskette dies ist ein prozess
der jahrzehnte in anspruch nimmt und
dessen erfolg erfahrungsgemäß alles
andere als garantiert ist ja und trotz
dieser tatsachen dürfen wir uns aussagen
wie die folgende anhören
bill gates vorhersagen zeigen das ist
zwischen neun monaten und zwei jahren
dauern könnte bis ein impfstoff
entwickelt ist ja genau das hat bill
gates gesagt und er sagte auch alle
menschen könnten nur dann wieder ganz
normal leben nachdem sieben milliarden
menschen gegen krieg not sind geimpft
worden sind wer würde es wagen will
geist so widersprechen dieser mann wird
doch als hochgradig kompetente und
glaubwürdige instanz in sachen
weltgesundheit und übungen gehalt in
einem früheren video haben wir euch
bereits darüber erzählt welchen einfluss
bill gates über seine stiftung auf die
politik der weltgesundheitsorganisation
bhu aussieht wir haben euch damals davon
erzählt dass die geld- stiftung
geleistet hat ein hinblick auf die
impfung von menschen in ländern der
dritten welt diese arbeit ist sehr
wichtig viele schwere krankheiten welche
in diesen ländern für einen kreislauf
aus armut und elend verantwortlich sind
können nicht anders als mit
flächendeckenden in programmen
ausgerottet werden andererseits erinnert
sich manch einer an bill gates hat dann
halt als knallharter geschäftsmann
dessen firma microsoft schaltete
mitbewerber mit rüben geschäftspraktiken
die angst und verunsicherung des
kampagnen aus um ein monopol zu
errichten in dem hunderte millionen von
kunden und anwendern systematisch
abhängig gemacht und benachteiligt
wurden viele sahen gates konzern
deswegen als das reich des bösen an und
die zur durchsetzung seiner ziele
angewandte strategie bekam sogar einen
eigenen namen hat die abkürzung für viel
an satellit bild dauert zu deutsch angst
verunsicherung und zweifel
die marketing-strategie microsofts
bestand auch darin kunden vom kauf der
konkurrenz produkt abzuhalten in dem
ihnen in vollkommen unrealistischen
ankündigungen das blaue vom himmel
versprochen wurde
wenn sie nur auf das kommende produkt
von microsoft warten würden und wenn
dieses damit großer verspätung herauskam
war es meist vollkommen unausgereift
instabil unsicher und enthielt viele der
versprochenen features gar nicht aber
microsoft hatte sein ziel erreicht die
kunden hatten ihr geld an microsoft
statt an die konkurrenz gezahlt und
konnten nun mit neuen leeren versprechen
über verbesserungen durch updates an der
nase herumgeführt werden
ist es also purer zufall dass uns die
aktuellen aussagen von bill gates
irgendwie an diese langjährige
erfolgsstrategie microsoft genannt
manche menschen hegen deswegen auch
heute noch ein gewisses misstrauen
dagegen dass gates seien auf diese weise
erworbenes vermögen um dazu einsetzt
seine privat agenda im gesundheitswesen
weltweit voranzutreiben vor allem daher
ist geschickt versteht sehr positiv
erscheinende ziele mit weitergehenden
forderungen zu verbinden mit forderungen
zur einschränkung von grundrechten und
mit einer groß angelegten digitalen
überwachung aller menschen so
durchsetzung einer allgemeinen
dienstpflicht für die umsetzung dieser
globalen überwachungsmaßnahmen stehen
seine firmen bereits mit fertigen
konzepten ungeduldig in den startlöchern
was soll man zb von einer meldung wie
der folge mithalten
[Musik]
produktion von zwei milliarden dosen des
unerprobten corona virus impfstoffs aus
oxford kann bald anlaufen
tja am ende dieses videos du hast du
genau verstehen die eine solche meldung
aus den nachrichten richtig einzuordnen
ist denn in zeiten wie diesen den zeiten
des umbruchs muss man sehr wachsam sein
und allen aussagen welche letztendlich
das leben und die gesundheit aller
betreffen genau auf den grund gehen
gerade wenn mächtige führungsfiguren von
allen menschen verlangen wir absolutes
vertrauen zu schenken ihnen die
kontrolle über ihr leben zu übertragen
und bürgerrechte ohne widerworte
abzugehen vor allem wenn sie damit
drohen dass anderenfalls dutzend
millionen von menschen sterben müssten
und der rest nie wieder in einer
normalen welt leben glücklicherweise
sind die prognosen des imperial college
wonach in der erster infektionswelle 40
bis 50 millionen menschen an cobit 19
sterben würden nicht eingetreten diese
horrorszenarien haben regierungen rund
um den erdball die begründung für
schwerwiegende lockdown maßnahmen
geliefert und hinterließen politik die
bevölkerung in einem automatisierten
zustand der angst und verunsicherung
viel konstatiert und alle wollen jetzt
nur noch eine impfung gegen cobit 19
plötzlich hat jedes land der welt einen
eigenen kandidaten für den sauerstoff
zwei impfstoffe dazu gehören die
vereinigten staaten china großbritannien
aber auch kleine länder wie die
tschechische republik oder spanien und
diese abhängigkeit vom heiß ersehnten
impfstoff hat überaus schwer wiegende
politische und gesellschaftliche konsens
[Musik]
kanada wird erst dann zur normalität
zurückkehren wenn ein corona virus
impfstoff entwickelt ist aber das könnte
noch in weiter ferne liegen
[Musik]
italienischer vizepräsident
biologielehrerin die normalität wird
gerade dann eintreffen wenn wir den
impfstoff haben ich denke ihr versteht
langsam den kern des problems viele
regierungen erwarten dass der impfstoff
innerhalb eines vernünftigen zeitrahmens
verfügbar sein wird neun monate zwölf
monate zwei jahre während dieser zeit
sollen die menschen einschränkungen
hinnehmen gästen geschlossen bleiben
warum auch nicht es geht ja nur darum
ein paar monate zu überstehen
die frage ist jedoch ob es überhaupt
realistisch ist zu glauben dass wir in
zwei jahren einen impfstoff haben werden
dieser frage werden wir in diesem video
schritt für schritt nachgehen um euch am
ende eine fundierte antwort nicht an so
können die er auch zu 100 prozent
nachvollziehen können und wie immer
dürfen wir dazu erst einmal einen blick
in die geschichte
wie man seinen körper täuscht was uns
zunächst einmal ein wenig in die
infektionsbiologie des corona virus
eintauchen als erstes muss ich aber
laura vielen vom lehrstuhl für
parasitologie an der karlsuniversität in
prag meinen dank dafür aussprechen dass
sie uns auf diesem feld beraten wird
damit ihr euch von dir sagen können was
passiert wenn wir mit dem corona virus
infiziert werden
stell dir vor ich werde infiziert mit
anderen worten das corona virus trinken
meinen körper ein was geschieht in
diesem fall das virus versucht die bände
meiner zellen zu penetrieren um sie zu
kapern und so umzuprogrammieren dass sie
neue kopien des virus herstellen
allerdings werden schon nach kurzer zeit
die ersten wären auf immunzellen weiße
blutkörperchen stoßen und diese stellen
sehr schnell fest dass dereinst ein
körper ein unerwünschte eindringlinge zu
weit vorgestoßen ist diese zellen sind
als signal an andere zellen des
immunsystems damit diese mit der
produktion von antikörpern beginnen
diese antikörper werden dann ausgesandt
um den viren dass daraus zu machen
[Musik]
wir werden diesen prozess immunantwort
und wie du dir vorstellen kannst müssen
die antikörper zur bekämpfung des corona
virus bis auf zwei speziell angepasst
sein sie müssen genau auf dieses virus
passen denn sie sollen ja nur dieses
virus bekämpfen und nichts anderes also
zum beispiel keine gutmütigen
darmbakterien dieser anpassungsprozess
dauert jedoch seine zeit mit anderen
worten mein immunsystem wird womöglich
tage damit verbringen verschiedene arten
von antikörpern zu testen ist es die
richtigen auf dieses virus passenden
gefunden hat sobald dies gelungen ist
muss es dann noch genügend diese
antikörper produzieren um das virus zu
zerstören das problem nun in der
zwischenzeit hat das virus bereits
millionen von zellen infiziert bot diese
hat es milliarden von kopien seiner
selbst erzeugen lassen nun muss das
system also ganz schnell die
antikörperproduktion hochfahren und den
vorsprung des virus einzuholen je
schwächer und belastete das immunsystem
eines menschen jedoch ist desto geringer
ist die chance dass ihnen dies überhaupt
gelingt deswegen verlieren viele
menschen mit schweren vorerkrankungen
und eben einem geschwächten immunsystem
diesen wettlauf und sterben so und nun
überlegt mal wie wäre es wenn das system
schon die richtigen antikörper kennen
würde
bevor das kroner währungs überhaupt in
meinen körper eingedrungen ist dann
könnte es mit der produktion der
antikörper sofort loslegen auch wenn die
zahl der bären noch sehr gering ist die
chancen dass wir uns zu besiegen würden
gewaltig in die höhe schnellen nun genau
darum geht es bei einer info
[Musik]
aufgabe des impfstoffs ist ist unseren
organismus zu täuschen erlaubt den
immunsystem eine infektion mit rotaviren
vor dieses erzeugt die passenden
antikörper und merkt sich deren bauplan
dies nennt man immun gedächtnis unser
körper lernt also mit dem virus
umzugehen und an dem tag an denen die
echte corona in version 1 trifft weiß
das immunsystem bereits welche art von
antikörpern ist zu bilden hat dies ist
das grundprinzip eines impfstoffs und
deshalb stehen standhalten die poly und
pocan dank impfstoffen vor der völlige
ausrottung ein der einen seite impfstoff
könnte daher auch profit munition ein
für alle mal in die ewigen jagdgründe
verbracht gut aber wie können wir das
immunsystem der erst täuschen nun dafür
gibt es im grunde fünf strategien die
erste ist dass cola virus selbst zu
nehmen ist jedoch zu inaktivieren also
das ist sich nicht mehr im körper
ausbreitet eine andere wäre es lediglich
zu schwächen damit sich die ausbreitung
in grenzen hält
diese beiden strategien werden nur von
wenigen impfstoff unternehmen angestrebt
dieses riskante die begrenzung der
ausbreitung im rahmen von vielen
milliarden von impfungen kann nur schwer
gewährleistet werden andere unternehmen
entscheiden sich daher für andere
strategien zum beispiel sogenannte
impfstoffe wie nur teile des virus
verwenden und andere labore wiederum
arbeiten mit sogenannten viralen
vektoren diesem impfstoffe die den nun
system genetisches material und
bestimmte proteine des virus
präsentieren und damit die gleichen
immunantwort hervorrufen als würde es
ein echtes virus betracht die
immunzellen bekommen quasi eine virustyp
chance zu sehen glauben aber da würde
sie ein echtes virus an machen und
schließlich gibt es noch einen anderen
viel moderneren typ nämlich nukleinsäure
impfstoffe auch gehen basierte impfstoff
so genannt und ich weiß was du jetzt
denkst wenn der wissenschaft schon so
viele verschiedene methoden sind warum
ist es dann noch immer so schwer einen
guten impfstoff zu entwickeln warum
nimmt man nicht einfach ein paar khroma
wird sie und fertig ist die in form nun
leider ist alles viel viel komplizierter
sehen wir es uns gleich mal an
warum dauert es so lange einen impfstoff
zu finden eine impfung kann vor allem
auf zweierlei arten schief gehen
entweder kann sich zu schwach sein oder
zu starkem mal darüber nach ein
impfstoff ist eines der wenigen
medikamente die der verabreicht bekommen
obwohl wir kerngesund sind dh ein
schlecht hergestellter impfstoff kann
eine zu hohe die us last habe und am
ende millionen von menschen infizieren
die eigentlich gesund war
glaubt ihr dass sein unwissenschaftliche
behauptungen einiger ein devecser
nein genau zu einer solchen fatalen
entwicklung kam es zum beispiel bei den
ersten tests die mit dem polo impfstoff
durchgeführt wurden
und in der tat sind genau solche
katastrophalen schlampereien wasser auf
die mühlen der entwächst sie fügen dem
hof der qualitativ hochwertigen
impfstoffe schweren schaden zu und
erhöhen die ablehnung gegenüber
impfungen in der gesamtbevölkerung ein
vermurkst zadar schädlicher kroner
impfstoff würde bei der derzeitigen
mediale aufmerksamkeit die in
gegnerschaft weltweit in die höhe
schnellen lassen allein durch die
tatsache dass dann viele menschen alle
arten von impfungen ablehnen würden
könnte unzählige menschen den kosten und
lange unter kontrolle geglaubten wieder
ausbrechen lassen auch diesem grund ist
es also gerade bei einem potentiellen
kronach impfstoff wichtig dass dessen
sicherheit und qualität in höchstem maße
sichergestellt sind
auf der anderen seite haben wir jedoch
das risiko dass der impfstoff nicht jede
immunantwort hervorruft nach den
besuchen
dies ist zum beispiel bei einigen aids
impfstoff kandidaten geschehen weshalb
ist der prozess einen impfstoff zu
finden so ungeheuer langwierig und teuer
allein forschung und klinische tests
können bei einem einzigen kandidaten
mehr als 200 millionen euro kosten und
dabei sprechen wir noch nicht mal im
ansatz von der massenherstellung gut
aber wie sieht das ganze nun im detail
aus nun zunächst muss man das antigen
fit und das heißt jene hauptkomponente
die unseren körper täuscht und die
spezifische immunantwort gegen das virus
auslöst normalerweise wird dieses
antigen mit einer anderen substanz
kombiniert die adjuvans genannt wird und
wie eine art katalysator wirkt das heißt
das immunsystem aktiviert und die
wirkung des rentiers verstärkt das
adjuvans selbst sollte dabei
selbstverständlich keine nebenwirkungen
aufweisen und bestens auf das antigen
abgestimmt sein und das alles nimmt sehr
viel zeit in anspruch und sehr sehr
viele versuche im grunde genommen muss
man eine repräsentative mutation des
virus reproduzieren isolieren hoben
daraus gewinnen und alle möglichen
optionen durch testen dieser prozess
kann gut und gerne zwei drei oder vier
jahren an
und das ist nur der erste schritt was
kommt dann versuche wie du dir
vorstellen kannst wird der
impfstoffkandidat zunächst man tieren
getestet bevor er an menschen
ausprobiert wird sechs affen denen ein
experimenteller corona virus impfstoff
aus bocs verabreicht wurde haben sich
nach starker exposition nicht mit
covidien angesteckt was hoffnungen auf
einen impfstoff für den menschen weckt
diese tierversuche werden als
präklinischen versuchen bezeichnet und
wenn man sicherstellen will dass es im
laufe der zeit nicht zum nebenwirkungen
kommt muss man die versuchstiere lange
beobachten denn viel neben der concorde
erst nach langer zeit auftreten oder
erst in verbindung mit anderen
arzneimitteln krankheiten oder bestückt
bedingungen wie zum beispiel einer
schwangerschaft es gibt also auch hier
eine ganze latte von optionen und
kombinationen die durch getestet werden
müssen wird da sind sie erst bei den
tierversuchen in diesem stadium bereits
werden viele kandidaten die zunächst
sehr aussichtsreich aussehen konnten
einfach verworfen bis zu diesem
zeitpunkt öffentliche universitäten
forschungszentren und private
unternehmen um lösungen aber sobald ein
impfstoff kandidat gefunden würde
debattieren wirkt geht es an die
klinische studien
das heißt menschen versuchen
corona des ersten patienten wurde in
britischer studie impfstoff initiiert
test am menschen sind der
komplizierteste teil dieses prozesses
ist tatsächlich werden tests in der
regel in mehreren phasen durchgeführt in
der regel werden sie in solchen fällen
an spezialisierte unternehmen
ausgelagert diese unternehmen werden
auftrags institute oder die hand genannt
denn daran dass diese tests eine riesige
zahl von sicherheitschecks umfassen in
einigen fällen sind gruppen von bis zu
1000 patienten erforderlich einige
erhalten den impfstoff andere als
vergleichsgruppe ein placebo
anschließend werden die wirkungen in
jeder gruppe untersucht und die
ergebnisse werden den
gesundheitsbehörden vorgelegt welche die
zulassung der impfstoffe überwachen
in den vereinigten staaten ist dass wir
zum beispiel die food and drug
administration fda zuständig in
deutschland das paul-ehrlich-institut
als bundeseinrichtung zum zeitpunkt
seiner vorstellung hat einen impfstoff
üblicherweise bereits zwei jahre
laborforschung zwei weitere jahre
tierversuche und zwischen fünf und zehn
jahren klinischer versuche hinter sich
denn nur so kann seine qualität
wirksamkeit und sicherheit gewährleistet
werden und mit etwas glück wird dieser
impfstoff schließlich von der regierung
genehmigt hört sich nach ganz viel
schufterei an nicht war aber an diesem
punkt haben wir noch immer einen
gewaltigen berg weitere arbeit vor uns
die massenproduktion
so und ich weiß was viele von euch jetzt
denken werden so ein bisschen produktion
das macht dich doch fast von alleine
so schwer kann das doch nicht sein
sobald wir die zauberformel haben gehen
wir in einem chemie verträgt der haften
alle notwendigen stoffe in einen großen
bottich und produziert impfstoffe wie am
fließband nun ich fürchte die realität
hat mir diese analysen vorstellungen
rein gar nichts zu tun denn eigentlich
sollten wir eher von impfstoff farben
sprechen als von fabriken es geht nicht
darum stoffe in einem bottich zu
vermischen sondern darum wie ihren
heranzuzüchten die man dann in spritzen
verabreichen kann zum beispiel verwenden
viel dieser impfstoff farmen dinge wie
hühnereier oder tabakblätter um das
virus darauf zu züchten und jeder clip
stoff benötigt eine ganz eigene
spezielle farben mit anderen worten
denen cupid 19 stoff wird man nicht in
denselben farben herstellen können in
denen auch impfstoffe gegen triple wären
oder irgendein anderes virus produziert
werden es müssen ganz neue labor und
farmen ausschließlich für einen
spezifischen impfstoff gebaut werden
[Musik]
ob das dauert mehrere monate oder gar
mehrere jahre
man braucht gebäude spezielle maschinen
und vor allem das personal das alles
muss geplant gebaut entwickelt geschafft
und eingestellt werden und nimmt viel
zeit in anspruch und viele dieser
aufgaben können dabei erst dann in
angriff genommen werden wenn überhaupt
feststeht welche spezifische impfstoff
überhaupt produziert werden soll und
nach welcher methode manche prozesse
sind nun mal stark sequenziell geprägt
sie können nicht nach belieben
paralysiert übersprungen oder skaliert
werden indem man einfach viel geld rein
schmeißt so wenn dann aber irgendwann
eine produktionsanlage steht kommt schon
die nächste mammut-aufgabe
wissenschaftler müssen das virus erneut
isolieren und ist so manipulieren dass
es als impfstoff in einer flüssigkeit
per spritze verabreicht werden kann und
ja wir sprechen die ganze zeit von
wissenschaftlern zu keinem zeitpunkt in
diesem prozess können wir uns einfach
beliebig die leute von der straße holen
und ihn einfach einen laborkittel
überziehen alle mitarbeiter in diesem
prozess müssen qualifizierte und
hochgradig spezialisierte fachleute sein
und ratet mal die wachsen nicht auf
bäumen sein müssen gründlich ausgebildet
werden und das kann ebenfalls viele
jahre dauern
aber nicht nur ausgewählte
wissenschaftler lassen sich nicht durch
einen finger schnippen herbeiwünschen
sondern auch die viren selbst welche wir
für den impfstoff brauchen auch sie
müssen sich entwickeln
bei mehreren und heranwachsen das ist
ein prozess der tage oder auch monate
dauern kann
und jetzt stellt euch vor um 7
milliarden impfdosen zu erhalten muss
dies alles auch sieben milliarden mal
ablaufen aber auch dann sind wir noch
nicht fertig denn jedes mal wenn eine
neue charge des impfstoffs produziert
und ausgeliefert werden soll wird eine
erneute qualitätskontrolle benötigt
denn es könnte er zum beispiel zu einer
mutation des virus gekommen sein wir
haben es hier nicht mit einem stück
software zu tun das auf knopfdruck
massenhaft kopiert werden kann
in der tat ist es erforderlich dass
jeder teil und jeder einzelne schritt
des herstellungsprozesses äußerst
peniblen und strengen
qualitätskontrollen unterliegt nur so
ist die wirksamkeit und sicherheit jeder
einzelne impfdosis zu gewährleisten
daher muss jedes einzelne land
inspektoren entsenden die wird prüfen ob
alle impfstoffe aus einem bestimmten
betrieb in einwandfreiem zustand sind
und nur wenn das alles gewährleisten ist
ja dann kriegst du aufatmen wenn du
selbst bei einer impfung bekommst denn
nur wenige andere dinge auf dieser welt
müssen so viele kontrollen durchlaufen
wie impfstoffe gesicht also das alles
ist ganz zu recht ein langer und
mühsamer prozess
und was ist jetzt aber mit all diesen
regierungen die behaupten sie würden das
alles in weniger als zwei jahren auf die
reihe bekommen ist so etwas möglich
haben die irgendwelche wundersamen
tricks oder superkräfte in der
hinterhand das sehen wir uns jetzt mal
etwas genauer an
ein impfstoff in 18 monaten nun im
grunde hofft man auf eine einzigartige
super tracht globalisierung und ganz
genau schaut die grundlage für die suche
nach einem impfstoff gegen profit 19 ist
versuch und irrtum je mehr
impfstoffkandidaten parallel ausprobiert
werden desto höher ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit einen treffer zu
landen und glücklicherweise hatten wir
noch nie so viele talente auf der welt
ist wie jetzt es gibt mehr als 100
impfstoff projekte und viele davon
kommen aus ländern wie china oder
singapur länder die vor 30 jahren noch
kaum aktiv auf diesem feld waren und die
jetzt in diesem wettlauf antreten können
weil hast du dich daran dass ich
verschiedene strategien aufgezählt habe
um einen impfstoff zu finden wie du
dieser grafik entnehmen kann es gibt es
im stoff projekt auch protein basis
andere auf der basis eines viralen
raptors und so weiter
viele verschiedene labore institute und
firmen haben sich also auf diese
verschiedenen wege begeben und viele von
diesen segen können zum erfolg führen
können nicht müssen aber drin ist
zurzeit alles das problem dieser
vorgehensweise ist natürlich dass viele
redundanz auch unglaublich viele
ressourcen anspruch all diese
wissenschaftler ärzte institute und
fähren werden natürlich an nichts
anderem forschen und arbeiten können die
leitung vieler millionen anderer
menschen werden dadurch vernachlässigt
werden aber das ist zurzeit nunmal der
globale konsens profit 19 hat oberste
priorität und wer an corona hobelt
interessiert sich nicht für die späne
die dabei entfallen bleibt also durch
die frage zu klären wer bezahlt das
alles nun ein teil dieses geldes kommt
von investoren und privaten unternehmen
aber die wollen dieses geld ja
irgendwann plus einen gewinn
zurückbekommen und da müssen natürlich
staaten einspringen
[Musik]
aris global response 7,4 milliarden euro
für universelle zugang zu impfstoffen
auf der anderen seite haben viele große
pharmaunternehmen gemeinsame projekte
sogenannte joint ventures ins leben
gerufen um impfstoffe herzustellen hier
ein beispiel
sanofi und glaxosmithkline wollen ihre
kräfte in einer beispiellosen im stoff
kooperation zur bekämpfung von cobit 19
bündel im grunde scheint sich die ganze
welt einig zu sein dass es notwendig ist
mehrere impfstoffe zu finden schließlich
jener beamten welche die pharmaindustrie
regulieren sollen daher sie nachrichten
wie die folgende einzigartig in der
geschichte engster forschung weiter
beginnt mit der erprobung eines
möglichen kroner virusimpfstoffe amt
menschen macht dich das nicht stutzig
haben wir nicht gerade erst lang davon
erzählt das ist jahre dauert bis ein
impfstoff am menschen getestet werden
kann und in diesem fall geht das alles
innerhalb von ein paar monaten
denn komik 19 war bis ende 2019 noch gar
nicht bekannt nun trotzdem führen schon
jetzt mehrere labore klinische tests an
menschen durch was ist da los also
eigentlich gibt es nur zwei erklärungen
die erste woche so die ganzen
vorschriften denen impfstoffe gegen alle
anderen krankheiten unterworfen sind
waren einfach nur nutzloser ballast und
wir sprechen hier von krankheiten wie ex
die zum teil millionen von toten
gefordert haben weiter was mehr als 19
sind all diese menschen also ganz
umsonst gestorben haben
unverantwortliche bürokraten aller
länder rund um den globus ihre rettung
gewissenlos verhindert oder
hinausgezögert aber nein doch das wäre
ja eine ungeheure und schier
unglaubliche verschwörungstheorie und
eine sehr unwahrscheinlichen obendrein
wie wäre es also mit der zweiten
erklärung die vorschriften haben
durchaus einen sinn
aber im fall von coop 19 sind die
regulierungsbehörden unter umständen
bereit das ein oder andere auge ganz
leicht zu drücken oder sogar beide ganz
fest so und genau darauf freut sich
schon eine ganz andere gruppe von sehr
die panischen menschen die anwälte
sondern ein impfstoff zu schwere
nebenwirkungen haben stehen bereits
armeen von advokaten gewehr bei fuß und
hersteller erste und zulassungsbehörden
zur rechenschaft zu ziehen weil ich
glück dass wir unsere anwälte haben denn
medizinische kunstfehler müssen ihren
preis haben und dieser preis könnte
viele pharmaunternehmen in den ruin
treiben
tja es sei denn sie können den schwarzen
peter den zulassungsbehörden zu chancen
und dann zahlt diesen preis inklusive
der anwaltshonorar der dass steuerzahler
beziehungsweise über den umweg der
geldpresse und anleihe käufe der
zentralbanken der sparer
na dann kann ja nichts mehr schiefgehen
gratuliere
oder meint ihr das pharma unternehmen
und behörden doch genügend anreize haben
die dinge in ordnung zu bringen dass die
sorgfalt vor finanziellen und
politischen profit stellen schreibt uns
eure meinung dazu in die kommentare
und was meine über bill gates dieser
engagierte sich ja vor allem auch im
bereich der massenproduktion von
impfstoffen
gates foundation stellt 50 millionen
dollar für die impfstoff initiative
gegen cupid 19 bereit die
gesamtfinanzierung übersteigt jetzt 300
millionen dollar wozu genau wird das
ganze geld verwendet nun es ist nicht
die forschung sondern die produktion mit
anderen worten die impfstoff farmen sind
bereits im aufbau begriffen wie aber ist
es möglich wenn es doch noch keinen
zugelassenen impfstoff gibt es werden
eben produktionsanlagen für einige
kandidaten vorbereitet es handelt sich
also um eine wette und sobald die
zulassungsbehörden grünes licht geben
die diese wette auf die massenproduktion
kann beginnen
folglich wird ein großteil des geldes in
gescheiterten projekten untergehen
wir sprechen hier von milliarden von
dollar die verpuffen werden das ist nun
mal der preis eines redundanten ansatzes
und all dies zu einem einzigen zweck um
die chancen zu erhöhen doch einen
wirksamen impfstoff zu finden
trotzdem lautet die kernfrage reicht
erst alles aus können all das geld und
all diese wissenschaftler garantieren
dass wir in zwei jahren einen sicheren
und wirksamen impfstoff gegen kuwait 19
haben werden sollen wir bis dahin
eingeschränkt leben nun die antwort
lautet nein wie gesagt es geht nur um
chancen nicht um garantien für viele
viruserkrankung hat man bis heute trotz
intensiver forschung keinen guten
impfstoff gefunden bei anderen dauerte
dies die jahrzehnte die viren mutieren
über einen solch langen zeitraum
natürlich was die anpassung des
impfstoffs immer wieder erforderlich
macht zum glück sind gerade coronaviren
gegenüber anderen zum beispiel
grippeviren äußerst konservativ fasste
mutationen angeht sie verfügen über gute
reparaturmechanismen und mutierenden
nicht ganz so wild was aber wenn es
trotzdem kein sicherer impfstoff für
alle sieben lehrern menschen gefunden
wird immerhin reden wir hier von sieben
milliarden menschen welche er zum teil
sehr unterschiedliche immunsysteme haben
vielleicht wird der impfstoff nur bei
einigen von ihnen mit wenigen
nebenwirkungen verbunden sein und eine
langanhaltende immunität hervorrufen
sollten wir es dann in kauf nehmen einen
minderwertigen impfstoff zu akzeptieren
oder sollten dann wirklich alle anderen
menschen zumindest alle ungeimpften ganz
nach der vorstellung von gates und ihnen
politikern mit eingeschränkten
bürgerrechten leben und nie wieder zur
normalität zurückfinden dürfen nun die
wahrheit ist dass selbst wenn man keinen
geeigneten impfstoff sitzen sollte es
durchaus wahrscheinlich ist dass
medikamente entwickelt werden um mit 19
zu heilen oder der akku schäbig zu
machen dass die menschheit damit zu
lieben kann
mit einer normalen grippe aber das ist
das thema eines anderen video center
haben noch viel zu besprechen wenn es um
die pharmaindustrie und das kostet
durchbruch bei corona virus therapie
extra meter so ist das erste medikament
das nachweislich leben rettet eine groß
angelegte studie hat ergeben dass ein
kostengünstiges und häufig verwendetes
der ried die sterblichkeitsrate bei
schwerkranken passierten mit 19 um ein
drittel senken kann
nature am 16 juni 2020
wenn du also die kommenden videos nicht
verpassen möchte ist drücke bitte auf
den knopf und auch aufs knöpfchen um
keines unserer updates zu verpassen und
schreib uns bittet in den kommentaren
welche meinung zu diesem thema hast hast
du es für sinnvoll dass die regierungen
weiterhin beschränkungen von
bürgerrechten und öffentlichem leben
aufrechterhalten ist wirklich ein
wirksamer und sicherer impfstoff für
alle menschen verfügbar ist so und bevor
wir zu ende kommen möchte ich mich noch
bedanken mein dank geht an laura willen
vom lehrstuhl für psychologie an der
karlsuniversität in prag san ignacio
lópez bonnie seines zeichens professor
für mikrobiologie an der universität von
navarra sowie allen mitarbeitern von
pfizer sanofi lexus is khan und der
universität oxford weil sie uns bei der
erstellung dieses video ist beratend und
mit detailinformationen zur seite
gestanden haben und falls ihr denkt dass
euch dieses video etwas gebracht hat
gebt uns bitte auch ein leck teilt ist
mit euren freunden und tschüss bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]